i don't know the world of figure skating
or anything like that but to me it seems
like
maybe the worst sport to go into for one
reason in my opinion
you're at the mercy of other of judges
and it really is such a subjective thing
i remember in the olympics at one point
i think it was france there was a couple
from france or something skating
together and they they found out that
the judge was sort of on the take he was
voting for his own countrymen or
something like that canada and russia
and in salt lake city olympics uh yeah
it wasn't france yeah so when you so you
go out and do a routine like in
vancouver or something yes and you think
you killed it and i did kill it yeah and
then let's say the judge comes back with
a shitty score yeah which is what
happened to you right
absolutely and i th it's all political
you know uh the guy who won is also
american you can only have one american
per podium basically it was in north
america i mean there there were lots of
things that went into it and i skated
the best i ever did and that's
you know unfortunately what i've got to
show for it and you have no option you
can't go and say hey wait a second i
just got robbed you just got to accept
it you got to have great sportsmanship
right yeah you bend over and you take it
do you think you were held back by these
judges do you think there was a
conspiracy against you i'm being serious
well there's a lot of everything i mean
the people that do judge us
are about half a century older than us
right so there is a cultural gap there
and in america alone i mean i i
train in russia part of the year i have
russian coaches i've i've never really
been
against any part of the world and
americans want patriots and people that
are pushing america forward and i love
where i come from and stuff but i think
the russian thing definitely turned
people off and then they gave me do you
think the judges were against you
because you trained in russia and
therefore you're not an american well i
mean are american judges i mean i've
heard it my whole career and constantly
being told okay your hair is too gay
you're training with a russian you
shouldn't speak russian you should uh
you shouldn't wear that kind of costume
this that you're wearing too much makeup
blah blah blah so they were biased
against you because you were too
flamboyant two flamboyant two
two just out of the box too unlike the
wheaties box that they wanted and it
seems to me
that you were good for figure skating by
being flamboyant in the same way that
liberace was good for the piano because
because they were playing it both ways
because they were playing up oh what is
he going to wear
you know how is he going to look is he
going to you know go along with the
judges and and tone down his outfit or
is he going to come out in full force
and so they were playing it up to bring
viewership to the olympics but then the
judges were still going to be the judges
do you think
there's an issue where gay men are
sitting and saying he's too gay and he
makes us look bad
absolutely that's why i've heard that a
lot that's what i think happened with
your career i'm honest to god that's
what i was saying that they were playing
it up for the tv cameras and on
you know to promote the show that he's a
rebel and he's going to break the mold
but by the same token they were still
going to vote in a very conservative way
right yeah because they think it's best
yeah well they think it's bad for the
sport but they started to realize you
know before this olympics i had a tv
show a reality series on the sundance
channel to be good johnny weir and that
was coming out and
my picture was everywhere and everyone
was talking about and they realized
maybe it's good that he goes to another
olympics and and you know he can bring
some attention to the sport we don't
need a young kid this time as our third
american we can just have johnny and
he'll bring us a lot of press right and
in some ways i feel like i went to this
olympics because
the people in charge knew that i would i
would bring
viewers